this is something i don't think we teach
young people well
and one of the things you may remember
this that was so striking about the tour
was that
i made a case fairly consistently that
most people
find the meaning that sustains them
through the vicissitudes of life
not in happiness but in responsibility
and that would bring everyone to a halt
it would always make the whole theater
silent it's like oh i never thought of
that connection
because maybe you want to avoid
responsibility and you can understand
why
i i think that's also it's a perfect
segue to chapter three which is do not
hide unwanted
things in the fog which seems to me we
live in a constant state of distraction
now you've mentioned twitter a couple of
times it's like
is twitter bringing any of us happiness
or is it keeping us all in a constant
state of fog any
you know the overload and the endless uh
obsession with politics that all seems
like
a fog to me you know i do my august off
the grid and and i do that
yeah i do that to get out of the fog
uh so what was so cute distraction is
definitely
fog and you you'll distract yourself i
think you distract yourself
mostly when your conscience is bothering
you because you don't want to
face what it is in your life that that
is uncomfortable
um that chapter is again quite practical
it
it it's a reminder to pay attention
often to negative emotion
resentment and that sort of thing
because it can tell you
well resentment is very useful maybe you
get
maybe your partner is talking to someone
and they're a little bit
more animated than you'd like and you
get jealous and
that jealousy is associated with a whole
set of insecurities
um or maybe they're flirting
then they shouldn't be it's not that
easy to determine and maybe you'll have
a big fight about that but
you could just as well pretend that
didn't happen
you know the emotion comes up i'm
jealous i'm resentful
it's associated with experiences like
that in the past the psychoanalysts
would have called that a complex
you could notice that you could think
well should i be jealous
is there something wrong with me or
there is there's something wrong with my
partner or there's something wrong with
the relationship
and you have to untangle that and
who knows what you'll have to untangle
to get that straight or you can bear the
jealousy and see what will happen in the
relationship or maybe it'll disintegrate
because your partner is flirting and
you ignore that it's not like you
repress it exactly and this chapter is
an attempt to distinguish repression
from
this hiding in the fog it's that you get
a hint that something's wrong
and then to and then you have to unpack
that hint to pull the information out
you know so maybe your partner is
flirting
and they shouldn't be and so then you
have to find out why they're
dissatisfied with the relationship or
what's tempting them or
or what is crooked in their soul at the
moment or
may or what they're dissatisfied about
terrible
journey of exploration and discovery you
know that's always presented as
something that's positive it's
it's often not at all it's so hard it's
like doing surgery on on a separating
wound it's and it's no wonder people
avoid it
but it's not helpful you know because
all it does is leave that
that those things grow and multiply in
the dark and if you ignore them they
just cascade
do you think that's just self-protection
for most people that most people they
they see it they know that
that truth behind them whether it's
about their partner or whatever it might
be
but they just it's just self-protection
like oh i just got to keep moving on as
things are that we're just creatures of
habit or something like that well
sometimes it's that and
it especially gets to be that if it if
it's if it's accumulated for a long time
because if you wouldn't have if you
wouldn't deal with it when it was a
kitten you're not going to deal with it
when it's a full-grown lion yeah
and so but i think mostly it's it's
something else i return to in the book
is it's deceit resentment and arrogance
i already know what i need to know
that's arrogance deceit is i don't have
to pay attention to that
and resentment is well things can go to
hell and so can he
or she you know and that's a that's a
pretty
dark triad and and you don't want
the spirit that embodies that to take
over your life
that's for sure well that's so that that
gets us to four then so the or
i think you got the order right on on
these because
uh chapter four is notice that
opportunity lurks
where responsibility has been abdicated
now i think yeah
i think we're seeing an awful lot of
that these days well that's a nice
inversion they because people are often
resentful if they see that
responsibility has been abdicated
why isn't that person doing their job
it's like well
hey man step in at your workplace
in your family you know when you think
well i don't i shouldn't have to do that
extra work well you shouldn't be
a slave you shouldn't allow yourself to
be tyrannized but
if something bugs you because the
responsibility is
going unfulfilled there's a great
opportunity for you
and this is something i don't think we
teach young people well
and one of the things you may remember
this that was so striking about the tour
was that
i made a case fairly consistently that
most people
find the meaning that sustains them
through the vicissitudes of life
not in happiness but in responsibility
and that would bring everyone to a halt
it would always make the whole theater
silent
it's like oh i never thought of that
connection because
maybe you want to avoid responsibility
and you can understand why
you can understand why you hide from it
like abraham
one of the biblical stories abraham he
stays in his father's tent till he's
like 80
and then god gets fed up and tells him
to get the hell out and grow up and
everything that he encounters is
catastrophic he encounters tyranny
uh the egyptians conspired to steal his
wife he encounters
starvation and war that is what you
encounter if you go out in the world you
think who the hell wants that i don't
want the responsibility it's like well
yes you do
as it turns out there's nothing better
than responsibility
now you know i say that with some
caution i think that
it's hard to say the responsibility
i've been overwhelmed by my apparent
responsibility
but i think it's also kept me alive and
i mean that literally
and so wait can you can you go a little
deeper with that i mean when you were at
your darkest moments in the last two
years
uh what whatever that might be um was it
the feeling of
there were many times in the last year
where it would have been much easier for
me just to be dead
that's constant
so but no
but is it but no because of something in
you or is it but no because of
the the people that you would have
abdicated that responsibility of the
people or is that
is that ultimately the same thing yeah
well i do think that that two aren't
easily distinguishable but it's
definitely that
it's definitely that
you know
and it's it's one of the chapters the
last chapter is be grateful in spite of
your suffering
you know
you need a meaning to sustain you
through suffering and it is the case
that you find that in responsibility
well and so it's good advice for anyone
who's at work
you're resentful about this and not
because people aren't pulling
their weight pull it see what happens
you become indispensable instantly
you'll know everything i know and if
and maybe that job won't be for you or
maybe that relationship won't be for you
but you'll take your
hard acquired wisdom go elsewhere and
flourish there
so you know i this kid stopped me i
think i wrote about this in this book
kids stopped me in a restaurant one day
when i was walking in he said
and he was he had an undergraduate
degree and he was working as a waiter in
a chain steak place
and he stopped me and he said you know
about six months ago i was watching one
of your lectures and i decided to stop
being resentful about my job
and he was resentful because he had a
university degree and he's working as a
waiter
you know and look i don't have anything
against waiters it's like
a waiter can make your evening you know
hooray
he said well i decided i'd start trying
at my job
like really trying as if it was
worthwhile he said he got
three promotions in six months like he's
just rocketing up the
power hierarchy well it's not power it's
competence
if it's well run you know and and
places are full of opportunity now
that doesn't mean social structures
aren't sometimes corrupt but
you can discover that too if you start
to take responsibility
and that goes sideways you're not being
credited with that
well then that's an indication that you
you need to
restructure the situation something's
corrupt about it
or if you can't do that you should go
somewhere else where
where that is valued it's a sign that
things aren't right if you're
if you bring your best to the table and
that isn't appreciated there's something
wrong with the table
now that doesn't mean that there's
something wrong with tables always and
everywhere but
it is the case you know that and this is
something we should all get straight
when we think about hierarchies it's
it's an axiom of the left
that hierarchies are predicated on
power it's like no
only when they're corrupt well they're
always corrupt well yes
that means they're all hierarchies are
contaminated with power
well that that isn't the essence of the
hierarchy the essence of the hierarchy
is
distinction of value and that can degen
you need the distinction of value
because you can't tell what to do
otherwise you have to do the first
things first that's a hierarchy of value
that's not power unless you're being
compelled
and then it's corrupt and you should
resist it if you'd like to see more
honest and insightful conversations with
jordan peterson himself check out our
jordan peterson playlist which includes
every interview i've ever done with him
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
both are right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell